the media doesn't get to tell generation
Z what socialism and capitalism is
anymore because these kids are living it
and that petrifies the left and it
should question of the day do you think
that Jim Carrey is is a clinically
insane B if he is what does that say
about the Hollywood elites surrounding
him who agree with his every word as
seen on Bill Maher when it comes to
socialism and how Americans are living
under Trump right now I always wonder
when I see Jim Carrey saying what do you
see are they just all that out of touch
or is it a touch of mental illness
perhaps I'd like to see your comments
let me know here's some context for
those who didn't see it on Bill Maher
last week Jim Carrey claims that it's
time to stop apologizing for being a
socialist and it's time to really push
it here we go we have to say yes to
socialism to the word and everything we
have to stop a posh I am here's what I'm
saying to me the socialism comments went
viral on Twitter more actually cut them
they cut them from the show as far as I
understand he cut them it you don't see
all of these quotes everywhere on all of
the platforms but we want to give you
context of the rest of the interview so
you could actually look at Jim Carrey's
claims and take them forth there so
again and left once less context we want
more let's go on to the claims so you
know that the Republicans are running
with the word socialism they're trying
to say and scare people scare people
onion ISM Venezuela Trump says we're
gonna be living in Venezuela because
it's the best example we'll probably
have true true socialism less money but
mainly because you said everyone loves I
don't think I don't think you really
wanna look at as well we said okay we'll
go along about his Weiland trail with
you you praised it all along with a
dictator other familiar socialist faces
by the way hit the notification bail
because subscriptions owe me anything
and join up at mug clubs look look
here's a proof
important forces we've had on this
planet belong is love you my friend as
an inch others 20 sometimes American
journalists talk about how bad the
country is people are lining up the food
that's a good thing what do you mean by
that
mr. Bernie Sanders necessary it's the
most important figure on this planet by
the way Captain Planet doesn't make
santos doesn't make that claim nobody
claims about superheroes regarding that
kind of importance so it's not the
republican screen people's comparison to
venezuela so left they've made these
comparisons for a long time until Chavez
experiment when completely soured the
country headed for a 1 million percent
hyperinflation people started starving
to death with citizens eating rats dogs
zoo animals to survive this is what
happened you pointed at Venezuela you
champion its cause and made it turned
around on you so you move on to the next
socialist country I grew up in Canada
okay we have socialized medicine and I
am I'm here to tell you that this line
that you get on all of the political
shows different people is that it's a
failure the system is a failure in
Canada it is not a failure in can I
never waited for anything in my life
anecdote I chose my own doctors and my
mother never paid for a prescription
anecdotal it was fantastic
untrue untrue by the way what war mold
that I fall into the Jim Carrey gets to
act as though he has the moral high
ground in combating a biased media
everyone people you've never this is
what you never hear everyone has heard
this everyone they use Canada as the
model and said it was how the United
States should model it's it's it's a
health care program you're just what
your gym you're just one in a long line
of celebrities and politicians who've
been selling this life specifically
Canada three years how does it happen
that here in Canada we're back to him
they provide only health care to all
people and I don't think there is any
debate that the quality of care here is
as good or better than the United States
ways of providing high-quality health
care that you have developed that we
need to know more about you know in
Canada they run their entire free
universal health care system federal
overhead total bureaucracy 1.7 percent
of the total healthcare budget
white-blue that's a wolf by the way this
this is a lie okay Canadian health care
is objectively worse than the United
States now we've done some videos on
this so you can go back and look at just
search in this channel socialized
healthcare Canada but difficulties his
examples which are anecdotal they have
the worst ER referral wait times but in
eleven developed countries fifty-six
percent of Canadians actually wait
longer than four weeks for treatment
compared to the US it's about twenty
four percent the average wait to see a
specialist in Canada is twenty-one weeks
at which point you don't need any more
my mom was looking at nine months for it
was at nine months for an MRI yeah nine
months for tomorrow and she got it
within about a month you have cash you
have a diamond that's how it was
socialized health care system you want
to know how long I waited 45 minutes yes
I got one new context when he says I
didn't have to wait well it was three
years when we had to find a family
doctor well I never had to pay for
prescription I said subscription I don't
know maybe they don't pay for magazines
we're taught in the face I don't know
what rules are there I have the paper
prescriptions okay for about 70% of
prescriptions that they want by the way
they don't have the same kind of
generics that you have the United States
certainly know when I was there but if
none of that convinces you if you're
still convinced by Jim Carrey's
anecdotal evidence to which he received
thunderous applause here's something for
you
the wait times were so bad in Canada it
was ruled a human rights violation by
the Canadian Supreme Court in shall we
vs Quebec to force somebody into the
socialized healthcare system well not
allowing them to pay for privatized care
as I've talked about this many times now
in Canada have you sing so in his super
hospitals as we know them in United
States hospitals dimension terminal
illness survival rates medical
innovation it's just I mean the list
goes on and on and on you know here he
goes on to again appeal to emotion there
are people who are sick but that's the
doesn't have to lose your home and as
your mother got sick only that's not
true and this is what they do they try
to appeal to emotion so know even if
lose your house because someone gets
sick but Obamacare is one of the
greatest taxes in the middle class that
we've seen in our lifetime who was left
footing the bill just have you talked
about with the housing crisis not that
people who qualify for the subsidies
paid for by the rest of America and not
the super wealthy who could afford the
skyrocketing premiums and deductibles
but the middle-class Americans who do
the subsidizing well you shouldn't you
shouldn't have to lose your house
because they get sick well should you
have to lose your house because you
actually had the right amount of money
saved for money down and you actually
got a fair loan you didn't go to the
subprime market and even go into the
health care exchange because you're
middle class and you're working she gets
screwed that way we only care about the
non-contributing zeroes amongst us why
do they get to dictate how the rest of
society lives hey I've never gotten my
crap together I don't work please next
clip nothing more socialistic than some
of the Pentagon programs that are just
jobs programs the Pentagon says we don't
want these tanks and they build them
it's not socialism in a nice way what
are they
sure enough socialists where do they go
to military war police okay there's a
difference when it come on 'ti in a
public good this is this is really
really easy police National Defense
their public goods health care college
Nestle tea commodities okay let me
explain what this means and then they
give you analogy actually you're the one
who taught this analogy Poppa Crowder
public goods are non-rival arrest
non-excludable that means non-rival rest
let's start with that that more people
can use them without any significant
additional cost
now this coudl means you can't keep the
extra people from using that good so
even free enterprise conservatives we
all agree the government should provide
public military defense for exam a
police force right things like free
health care free college aren't really
public goods because it costs a lot more
for each additional patient or person
you add to the list and you can easily
keep them from using it this is a
referee analogy that was actually given
to me by um you pop a credit the analogy
for the legitimate role of government
like hockey referee okay it's to keep
the players the citizens safe right from
both internal and external but someone
might be throwing you know a big gulp
and they're supposed to say from that or
an octopus in hockey it's incidental to
the play you keep your whistle in your
pocket we're not soccer
come on role of the government to keep
us safe okay so what falls into
legitimate purview of government of
course a military yeah of course things
like borders of course things like
enforcing laws to make sure that other
people aren't hurt by law breaking
citizens we're not saying there's no
role to government we just don't think
that everything is a human right well
it's the economic equivalent of the free
speech argument you make where these
people make their bones right and they
shut the door behind them right the same
thing here yeah let's go back to the
first point people should apologize for
so should people of South apologize for
socialism he's saying other people
shouldn't yeah you should you should
socialism and it's cousin who's aged
slightly less gracefully communism they
try to they try to separate those two
you really can't if you look at them
historically has led to insanely brutal
regimes under the USSR mile Castro
Chavez should I keep going
and all those regimes by the way were
initially praised by the same leftist
elite and academics of America just like
celebrities of Venezuela you can go back
and find the same elites praising Castro
and Soviet Russia every mile I mean a
dog recently praised Mao I think it was
like 2012 she's somebody does their
homework I you know I was I remember I
was on a panel I think with Doug's shown
on Fox News well she wasn't praising now
and I'm gonna oh this guy has no idea
what's about to happen
done praising mouth yeah when it comes
to long term endorsement the left has a
monopoly on batting a hundred for
sucking okay by the way communism we all
saw that religion communism has led to a
hundred million dead over the last
hundred years you know far far more than
we're talking about even just religion
that's a lot of people that's a lot of
there's a lot of people right they
pointed to Russia yeah I didn't work any
see what they pointed to Cuba maybe so
whatever then they put it up in as well
you just saw them recently pointing to
Venezuela and then that didn't work I
mean went back to China I don't know
what happened up here the Democrats seem
to get a plan to fight this sweat this
slander of socialism you're gonna be
living in Venezuela I don't see we have
to say yes to socialism for the word and
everything do we have to stop a posh I
am okay you want to know how I know that
Jim Carrey loves capitalism a hundred
million whoa and if that weren't enough
here's another little tidbit just just
from that very segment on Bill water I
went out today and bought me some Nikes
[Applause]
salute to Colin Kaepernick to Nike
congratulations on a fantastic Colin
Kaepernick who wants to loot the flag
with will salute Colin Kaepernick Nike
of all companies the same Nike famous
for exploiting sweatshop labor
conditions in other countries that we
don't allow in our capitalist system the
United States
this is shows you how incoherent Jim
Carrey's worldview is it's worse than
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind I
know you all try to act like I know
what's really going on there thank you
don't know somebody fan theories with it
in Donnie Darko shut up stop trying
actually have a handle on it you don't
it's just so funny that they use right
now of all times this is why I don't
know if he's crazy he's just completely
out of touch right now of all times to
push for socialism yeah look here when
they were talking about Donald Trump
they said he would rate as a he would
rate his job performance as very good
and and Jim Carrey goes as what a
demolition man and everyone claps like
yeah what is he what our economy is not
only the best in the world it's doing
insanely well right now by our own
metrics the jobless rate lowest point in
half a century that since the moon
landing woman rate pretty low a all-time
low ever ever everyone said that Donald
Trump was delusional for suggesting that
he could even achieve 3% growth I think
actually what did the brian Stelter was
he mentally stable is that the 4.2
percent he was delusional and mentally
unstable for promising 3% 4.2 do you've
any idea how significant that is in the
realm of economic it's just bizarre to
me that they pick right now to [ __ ]
about free enterprise and try and push
show schools' them and here's what I
think the left is petrified of another
baby boomer generation because why free
enterprise capitalism is working really
well
as we've just pointed out we have an
entire generation of people some what
Millennials but Generation Z who had
never actually seen capitalist markets
doing as well as they have now four
years the left told
the capitalism was a failure socialism
was the answer up until now the
generations hadn't really seen a free
market right they had they had George
Bush Bill Clinton George W Bush and
neither of whom were really Republican
nothing was really all that conservative
certainly not economically followed by
eight years of Obama but now with Trump
following Obama the left is terrified of
Carter being followed by Reagan 2.0 yeah
sure when people were young right they
thought they wanted Carter a hippie
free-love and Carter he seems like a
nice guy he wears a sweater the White
House there and put some solar panels on
wore a sweater you keeps a little bit
cooler in the winter farms peanuts what
could go wrong what could possibly go
wrong and so they thought they wanted
Carter's and Reagan happen and they
realized they had more money in their
pocket and they didn't have to wait in a
gas line so the Bene one generation grew
up from pot smoking hippies into the
conservative yuppie stereotype that you
see today
suddenly generations who are sold on
socialism are now seeing the positive
and personal effects of free enterprise
in their lifetime more so more
importantly in their own lives so how do
I mean greater job opportunities for
themselves big time keeping more of
their own money for themselves the left
knows and is terrified especially
because they appeal purely to selfish
motives disguised as compassion they are
terrified of generation Z after
Millennials upon whom the left they've
had a they have footed generation Z with
a massive bill and like the baby boom
generation Generation Z which is the
most conservative generation at this
point in their lifetime ever many one at
this point in their youth they're more
conservative than baby boomers they are
going to be even more conservative once
they get older because now they've seen
the contrast between a crappy economy
under Obama and a flourishing economy
under Trump up until this Trump boom the
media was able to sell an entire
generation on the contrast of terrible
unsuccessful capitalism and
compassionate democratic socialism
that's where we've used right but now
the generation is living it they're
living the contrast of one of the worst
job economies ever for people under 30
in accessibility to health care even if
you work for a living particularly you
work for living in a Barack Obama now
it's being contrasted with more money
left in their paychecks more jobs
available more free-market options
available than ever before whether it's
health care whether it's good take your
pick more choices than ever before under
President Trump the media doesn't get to
tell Generation Z what socialism and
is anymore because these kids are living
it and that petrifies the left and it
should like this video watch another one
of our videos or subscribe at the
notification bell those don't really
mean anything anymore today in YouTube I
would say hit a like with a thumbs up
but that might be gone or comment below
but that most likely will be censored so
bookmark the page of course if you're
using Google Chrome they'll find a way
to [ __ ] with your bookmark so just join
up at Laura's credit com / moncla that's
a lot of credit calm / mug Club you get
a hand at SH mug and you get access to
the full daily one-hour show and you're
not beholden to Susan Wojcicki / Clint
Howard